es un gesto que debe repetirse una y
otra vez encontrar el ritmo adecuado
para quizás un día salvar vidas
después de practicar los masajes
cardíacos siete veces me doy cuenta de
que se necesita mucha fuerza en los
brazos y el estómago
es una situación real creo que sería
difícil hacerlo bien
entre los 40 voluntarios la mayoría son
novatos este surcoreano de 26 años ya
aprendió estos gestos en el servicio
militar obligatorio para todos los
hombres del país
cuando estaba en el ejército no lo
tomaba en serio
me preguntaba si alguna vez tendría que
utilizarlo de verdad
y no me di cuenta de lo importante que
era hasta el accidente
el accidente el 29 de octubre las calles
de seúl se llenan para Halloween pánico
en un callejón estrecho
158 personas mueren aplastadas por eso
vinieron todos estos jóvenes
fue tan impactante
esas imágenes aún me persiguen
Incluso hoy Durante este curso pienso en
ellas
me entristece y me recuerda la
importancia de este curso
habría ayudado que más gente supiera ser
un masaje cardíaco
a pesar de ello habría sido complicado
salvar muchas personas porque debe
hacerse en los cinco minutos siguiente
al paro cardíaco
muchas personas se están traumatizadas y
el primero entre los supervivientes se
la tragedia como este francés que
estudia biotecnología en seúl desde
agosto es una de las pocas víctimas que
accedió a responder a nuestras preguntas
estaba en medio de la multitud estaba
pegado a una pared había alguien tanto
me puñetazos en la espalda y empujándome
se veía que estaban enfadados empujaban
a todo el mundo y así había gente al
lado de ellos
muchas personas sobre todo en el metro
ahora sufren la ansiedad o agorafobia
durante la primera semana había mucha
gente que no se sentía bien
aunque no hubiera estado allí
todavía sucede
soy un poco más cauteloso cuando veo a
la gente
tengo un amigo extranjero que desde
itaiwán lo pasa muy mal cuando hay mucha
gente e incluso
de vez en cuando se siente triste sin
motivo
para hacer frente al trauma colectivo
las autoridades suplicaron el número de
autobuses de apoyo psicológico en 35
vehículos repartidos por todo el país
cientos de personas recibieron
asistencia gratuita de psicólogos
rompiendo el silencio en este país
tradicionalmente pudoroso con los
sentimientos
antes los coreanos no éramos conscientes
de la Salud Mental
nadie iba al psiquiatra
pero hoy en día la depresión y los
trastornos mentales se tratan por fin
son enfermedades reconocidas
comunicar y para algunos denunciar
en esta manifestación organizada por
estudiantes la tristeza dio paso a la
rabia
como hoy está lloviendo tenía que
hubiera poca gente
pero de hecho hay muchas personas esto
demuestra que muchos de nosotros
queremos que el presidente renuncie
estos manifestantes acusan al propio
jefe de estado de ser el responsable de
la tragedia el motivo fue el traslado de
su oficina el pasado mes de septiembre
lo que provocó que casi se duplicara el
número de agentes de policía requeridos
para la protección del presidente
el accidente estuvo relacionado con el
traslado del despacho del presidente su
nueva oficina está muy cerca del lugar
de la tragedia el presupuesto para el
traslado seguía aumentando y cada vez se
necesitaban más agentes de policía para
garantizar la seguridad del presidente
no quedaban suficientes hombres para
proteger a los ciudadanos es tan absurdo
se necesitan unos 700 policías para
garantizar la seguridad del presidente a
diario mientras que en la zona de la
tragedia solo había 137 hombres
disponibles esa noche para controlar a
una multitud de más de 100.000 personas
el presidente surcoreano se ha
disculpado y está previsto que una
investigación arroje luces sobre
posibles irregularidades
[Música]